Melvin Melvin brother of the joker
Melvin Melvin brother of the joker I'm
cool
oh hi I am Melvin the brother of the
Joker sure love you haven't heard of me
but I am the brother of yes the infamous
Joker you know why so serious you know
all that stuff uh actually I too have
been working on my own
catchphrase um spewpa these foolish may
not be as catchy but I I think it works
so yeah all right first of all I like to
welcome all the newcomers to my blog
hello
hopefully we're going to talk a lot
about evil lots of nasty evil evil I
repeat myself I guess it doesn't matter
um you know cuz evil does repeat itself
it's all about getting that massive I
don't know where I'm going with that
anyway okay so today's secret subject or
in a secret diabetes is all secret don't
don't tell anybody but you know today's
a big I would say big subject is
ray-guns now the thing about ray guns is
that they are very very expensive as I
found out so so what you're gonna want
to do if you want to get a ray gun
there's all sorts some ray guns that you
can get there's um
there's my secretary she is to keep it
down I said I will Reagan's um now I had
someone who is actually working on
Oregon as we speak and no it is not my
mother I should probably address that I
do in fact live with my mother shame to
say that I just take a little longer to
get going as opposed to other people
I see no shame in it even though she
constantly does so basically well okay I
just lived her about 50 vicodin so I
think we're good now what got you
thinking oh okay
I just looked a whole packet of nyquil
into her milk she's getting a little mad
now
so yeah Reagan's I see a lot of feelings
using them but um let's be honest
you don't need them what is it that a
laser gun can do that a normal gun can't
do destroy a city sure but if you get a
gun that's big enough it could do that I
don't know where you buy the bullets but
I'm sure they're out there I'm sure they
are out there massive massive bullets
okay maybe a rate gun will be a very
very good thing to get I don't know but
I do not have the money for some I've
been debating whether or not how to I've
been thinking thinking how to get some
bullets not bullets a cat my mind I just
can't
I'm sorry I just just been under a lot
of stress you know I still haven't
gotten the job you know what am I
talking about
Evil's my job yes because I am Melvin
the brother of the Joker did you wake up
I hope you had a better mom so um yeah
ray guns I don't see the necessity
so I do not see the necessity but I will
somehow get one actually I have a friend
who was actually building me what he he
works at Circuit City I think I will
just give him a call right now
hey Bea how you doing now
Melvyn popcorn
the brother of the Joker yeah yeah
that's right I didn't think you forget
me so um yeah how's our uh how's our
array guy doing there uh-huh
well what uh I see you
well does it still shoot lasers like we
thought oh well how large is it to it so
that's like that can fit in my pocket
it's not really a gun there's more of a
toy well what does it fire fires cashews
well that that's not going to be very
threatening to the hero is it no it is
not I don't care if the hero's allergic
to nuts it's not gonna work okay okay
calm down calm down not talking to you
I'm talking to me no no I did bad didn't
mean to yell eleven no really want me to
sing it now I there's a place all over
the world we will see each other well
throughout the night
okay so I can't remember the words okay
I don't care you know what you know what
I don't care I don't care I am evil and
I'm going to destroy it with or without
your cash you got goodbye No
yeah see you Tuesday yes
so yeah I'm realizing this wasn't a very
good beginning blog if you would um but
my guess is that the next ones are gonna
be better cuz I gonna do a lot more
robbing a lot more stealing of things
and maybe just maybe I might pants
somebody maybe a certain somebody with
pointed ears and wears all black that's
right the human ant I'm gonna get him
yeah okay human antes now as big as
someone like Batman or Superman but he
is still a very impressive superhero I
don't think it matters a lives right
next door to me I think that's still
very very impressive I know what
superhero that can obliterate none of
Larry that's what I do that can save
people from me up littering the world
yes yes this very impressive sir that's
a lot better than the half of the people
you know so just to reiterate Reagan's
wasted of time the human ant is mine
arch arch nemesis I can't talk today oh
I think that's it this will be the first
of many evilness that will be coming so
uh again this is Melvin brother of the
Joker signing on yeah I'm comin mom okay
Melvin Melvin brother of the Joker
Melvin Melvin brother of the Joker I'm
cool